نعم عبد السلام ما اكده الزميل علي نؤكده
الان من خلال وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
الشهيد ثاني في جنين اذا سقط حتى اللحظه
شهيدان وفق تاكيد وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
والشهيدان هما ليس من كان في داخل المنطقه
المحاصره هما سقطا برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الذي يطلق النار بشكل عشوائي
عند عده مداخل لمخيم جنين وايضا هناك على
الاقل ثمان اصابات وصلت
للمستشفيات بطبع احد هؤلاء هذين الشهيدين
هو كان قد وصل اصلا في حاله خطره جدا
باصابه مباشره في منطقه البطن واستشهد في
المستشفى بالنسبه للوضع او التصريحات
السياسيه ايضا كما ذكرت عبد السلام
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه تؤكد في ان مجازر
واعتداءات الاحتلال في جنين ونابلس تاكيد
اسرائيلي على اختيار مسار التصعيد وبالطبع
تحميل الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامل المسؤوليه
عن تداعيات التصعيد وارتداده حسب وصفها
على ساحه الصراع ايضا فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بدات تصدر بياناتها للتاكيد
على ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه متواصله نعود
ونذكر باخر التحديثات ايضا وفق شهوده عيان
ووفق ما رايناه عبر عده وسائل اعلام
ووسائل التواصل على الاقل المقاومون
تمكنوا من اسقاط مسيرتين اما كانتا
تستخدمان للتصوير او لاطلاق الرصاص شكرا
لك جوهر البديري سنعود لك بطبيعه الحال